[Music]
welcome back to the games foot stage
here at e3 2018 I'm Lisa James joined by
Mike Mahadi and with us is Jason Connell
art and creative director of ghosts of
Toshima we're showing all the biggest
games from the show this week and I've
got to say both of us are incredibly
excited about this one Oh awesome Jason
how's your show going I'm sorry how's
your show going oh it's great man like
this is a it's been everyone's been so
excited a lot of good stuff you know
PlayStation had a great conference it's
been great so on Monday we got to see
like a first look at gameplay from the
game and it kind of blew us all away so
can you talk a little bit more about it
one thing I noticed immediately as like
minimal hard elements is that gonna be
indicative at the final game so our goal
with the ghosts decision demo was really
to when we set out to figure out what
would be the best thing to showcase of
the world was you know we want to have
this there's so many things we could
show and we really wanted to go for what
is the most striking the most minimal
the and and and therefore the things
that did showcase really well like you
know the first time you strike somebody
the open-world you know Vista we wanted
that stuff to sing so actually we we
reduced because our goal with the studio
is to be a little bit more minimalist
approach to the direction to the game so
we reduced the the HUD down to the only
the core elements there will be UI but
we wanted to just keep it a little bit
more minimal for the demo so we talked
about the premise of the game where we
are what we're doing yeah so goes to
Tsushima
open world action-adventure game it's
super inspired by real events that
happen in around 1274 but you know we're
taking an original story we have an
original hero
the island our goal if you look in that
the trailer there's this shot where you
climb up to the top of that Vista our
goal with the game is if you can see it
we want you to be able to go to it and
that that shot is to you know we wanted
to say like this is a huge huge open
world it's pretty ambitious project for
us yeah and it's also like a specific
time in history whether I mean I'm sure
you're going more for a historical
fiction kind of thing but what is it
about this time of history in history
that was so appealing
for the storyline in the world of chima
well it's actually not been done very
much most the time into NATO period yeah
and it's kind of interesting to go a
little bit further back and dig into
that you know those those little pieces
that people may have not touched too
much right I read that when you guys
were scouting the location for Tsushima
you were afraid at my leak because it
there was a tiny article in like a local
newspaper is that right oh man I'm glad
this comes out yeah good old Billy
Harper our animation character director
yeah he gave his business card out
somebody and somebody wait they were so
excited and everybody has been so
supportive on this project everyone
we've met when we went to Japan J studio
we have so many people just excited to
help us and and they were too and they
were so excited they published it in the
local newspaper oh my god you know
almost became a leak and that was you
know before we had debuted anything like
soccer punch and Tsushima Island in
Japan so that had been interesting they
didn't happen though so I didn't been
leaked for lucky so it's a fun story now
yeah train record it was fun yeah Billy
avoided a crisis yeah he's awesome um
I'm curious like looking back through
sucker how long have you been at sucker
punch personally I think going on eight
years okay yeah so like looking back at
sucker punch is history back with like
the infamous games and everything like
this is not your first open-world game
I'm curious what from the company's past
have you like kind of mind or been
inspired by or borrowed from to go into
ghosts of Tsushima oh you know I think
that uh at least personally throughout
my career I've always cared a lot about
you know cinematography and photography
and lighting and with this comes an
opportunity especially if you look back
on great samurai films there's there's
you know Kurosawa films there's a
dedication to the cinematography to tell
a story and you know I like I think that
this is a unique opportunity for us to
bring some of that in mostly it's about
pacing like even in that first strike he
doesn't just like run into it we hold a
little bit and like we set some tension
ups to make that strike feel bigger and
all of those things have helped
influence along the way just as we can
see it going on right now when it comes
to the combat is it kind of like stance
based I'm thinking
it reminded me a little bit of foreigner
you could see like the main character
would go into a stance and the lady
would kind of yeah try my job is that
correct yeah so the goal with the combat
especially what we've shown here and the
in the we call that the mud pit is a
couple things it's one we really wanted
to combat to plant two into the world so
if you're in leaves you're gonna kick up
leaves if you're in the mud you're gonna
get mud you know splashed all over if
you do a bunch of roles you'll just get
caked and mud if it rains it goes away
we really want you to be plants in the
world and if the combat experience the
actual combat experience we really want
it to be we call it mud blood and steel
but we really want it to be fairly best
for all times the violence I push it a
little bit more when when when you're
maybe like on a finishing move or it
towards the end of the fight and it's
more about balancing the amount of guys
that are around you I said if every
single fight has to be a one-on-one
there are definitely one-on-one moments
we see some in here but it's more about
balancing the guys around you right
considering this world this setting and
obviously like after the game was
revealed last year people were saying
like oh it'll be like an open world
stealth game like I'm curious how like
stealth aspects as like kind of like the
first ninja whatever will factor into
this yeah so you know the title of the
game goes to sea Shima so this guy's
name Jin Sakai his narrative is that he
is this samurai and once two islands
been taken over he's kind of got to
change his ways a little bit learn from
some of the people that he meets along
the way in order to become the you know
the ghost of Tsushima and so this entire
section here in the temple here is
actually kind of a show showcasing a
little bit of that he's climbing up
these ledges here he's using a grappling
hook he's taken the drop down on enemies
and taking him out really quick and one
of my favorite ones is the the Shoji
assassination so all of those are kind
of against the grain and it will have to
be learned along the way so it's like a
like a skill tree kind of thing that
will be or it really are these just
abilities that he just kind of learns
it's not gonna be a branching skill tree
or anything it is your kind of abilities
I have learned okay so you can see right
now the the mega violent part I think of
this demo oh yeah yeah this one's this
one's fine this one that's really cool
yeah like who's been especially like it
seems like he's slowing down time
can you like sync up abilities that way
yeah so this is a chain assassination
that where he can take the drop on a
group of guys and and if he you know
hits the button the right time before
the next one is hot you know there's a
time period we hit at the right time
you'll go and get the next one and so he
finishes them all and then and then this
is actually a separate move there's
still one guy left and we could have
gone around to hit him from the front
but we wanted to show the the shoji
assassination so if he'd gone and got
that guy before he started to blow his
horn yeah what would happen because
obviously the reinforcements would come
yeah yeah same same thing yeah yeah if
it's like if he blew the horn that
obviously the reinforcements would come
but you were you know you could go
around the other side and hit them or
you know most people usually take the
show Choji if it's there yeah so it's a
pretty appealing three outside sources
outside of sucker punch that
particularly inspired the scheme from a
gameplay perspective mechanic
perspective yeah you know I think we
played a lot of games you know I think
from an art perspective there's all
kinds of game that inspire me you know I
play a lot of a lot of games legend
Zelda I love that game you know I play
quite good I could probably keep going
on the list but in the gameplay
perspective I think estudio is inspired
by a lot of combat games a lot of we
take our experience from some of the
infamous games I think that we've gotten
a lot of questions about the parkouring
over the ledges and you know yeah that's
obviously something we've done a lot of
em so yeah we take a lot of inspiration
from a lot of different projects so
infamous first light was 2014 and so you
guys waited like three innovate years
yeah working in secrecy what's it been
like to finally get to announce and show
the game off to the world oh it's it's
the best feeling you know it's a it's a
really ambitious project for us you know
it's y-you know it takes some time
before we're ready to show the world but
extremely ambitious but it's not worth
doing if it's not ambitious right so if
we were doing something that wasn't
ambitious and it was super safe I don't
think it would be as exciting and
therefore you know people may not be as
excited about it so I'm really glad we
took it on and it feels great to get
here and show it but obviously like your
relationship with Sony is incredibly
strong in especially when the
PlayStation 4 was coming out it was
infamous interest interest yeah what's
it been like having their backing on a
project that
you said is incredibly ambitious yeah
you know Sony as an organization has
been really helpful since the very
beginning of us pitching this game you
know from the execs to some few folks at
Jay Studio had kind of some insight and
some help with a narrative so even early
on we had a lot of support but this week
once we've opened it up to all the other
first party studios and other teams that
have seen it it's just been an
overwhelming like hey if you guys need
anything you know really excited for you
like it's been an incredibly supportive
soive we're in a really neat position I
feel really lucky it helps us make this
game we were just watching that duel on
the gameplay before in like in under the
the falling leaves and everything I
think was one of the most gorgeous
things during the show but and you were
mentioning you kind of got like you know
like the Seven Samurai Icarus our films
and your like your passion for
cinematography is it difficult to
balance like cinema like a cinematic
story with like something that's also
you know it's a game so anything fun
yeah yeah absolutely but there are ways
they're really really interesting in
tricky ways that you can make it great
like even even in the duel when you're
you know fighting
misako under the you know dread tree the
leaves are all around the duel actually
starts with a higher camera it's a
little bit higher it's not as dramatic
because it's higher and as you know the
fights go on and you know getting closer
and closer to it you know beating it the
camera gets lower and lower and lower
and that is a simple simple simple trick
that you can do that doesn't actually
mess up gameplay but gives it a much
more empowering the characters are
bigger on screen it's much more dramatic
their stances feel bigger and you're not
doing anything except for just doing
this to this so there's very simple
things that we try to employ to help
that and did the actual combat like like
you're obviously fight those three guys
at the beginning and then you go in this
stealth section that does the combat and
that duel actually changers they're just
purely perspective that changed from the
cameras point of view so you can I mean
that duel when we have duels in the game
they were going to be you know very
narrative based this one is a narrative
based thing it's not going to be to be
random you know it's gonna be if we're
gonna build the tension we want to build
those scenarios and each one will be
around some unique element you saw the
red tree in this one and you can play it
will be
in that specific area that will happen
and you can look this way this way this
way you have full control of the camera
not just kind of stepping up hard pushed
here you can move it around whichever
way you want we chose to keep it a
certain direction because we thought it
was very beautiful but you know we can
move in any way we want just watching
the game playing from Monday as well
there's a host in the game you know what
the internet is like they will latch on
to that horse like Roche from The
Witcher for example thought was gonna be
going with us the whole journey was it
just like what else is there so we'll
talk a lot more about the horses in
their play in a game later but I will
say I'm quite fond of the horse that we
have his name is Nobu and he is in the
game and I think his name means trust
but he's uh it was we we want to
showcase that Jin is a compassionate
character you know and and have him
having a relationship with that horse is
a way to showcase that by giving it a
name simply actually showcases that
could you talk a little more about the
actual I'm sure you're not gonna reveal
too much but the story itself and you
mentioned like the the time period takes
place in and we kind of know that like
to me at least based on the trailers a
lot people it looks like it's this it it
goes to Tsushima he's saying like we
don't need pride or honor anymore we
need to just need to win and then that
kind of develops like this guerrilla
tactics thing I'm curious like could you
talk more about that the story in that
regard yeah so in our debut trailer we
showcased a very smart enemy talking
kind of down to him and then and and in
the story is very similar to what you
actually just said is that you we want
to establish a world with us very smart
enemy it's not just you know I'm gonna
come in top everybody up you know
there's tactics and you have to play
this samurai shinsekai
who most of his friends are dead and
even though most of his friends are dead
he wants to still behave like a samurai
but some of the people that he's meeting
along the way kind of helped change his
mind a little bit help make him think
that there are other things I need to
try to do to win and yeah he has to
change or he will not save the island so
that's the narrative journey that he'll
be going on one of the things that
interested me is the language so you are
offering you can a Japanese voiceover
track you play with subtitles but in the
demo we saw he came up against the [ __ ]
hordes and they were obviously speaking
in different language because there
weren't subtitles on that I was
wondering if it's June gonna be able to
understand that so we are we the player
going to be told that or is just kind of
left to the image I think what what I
will talk more about that later too but
you know one of the goals with we talked
about this a lot in the studio should
the Mongolian army speak and kind of
English or should they be and subtitled
and one things that we actually found is
when they were in Mongolian and you
didn't understand anything at all and we
have these great voice actors its way
scarier yeah I kind of got that it
really works I are we really shocked you
know so we were kind of leaning into
that right now it's an ID on whether or
not we actually put in the only English
subtitles up or other methods to help
you understand what exactly is going on
but but we we really wanted to showcase
that and so we wanted to be committed to
saying you know what they're gonna speak
Mongolian was it difficult trying to
strike it seems like a much darker tone
than I would associate sucker-punches
folio with yeah was it difficult that
transition into that I liked it so and
gets I think it's I I kind of naturally
we'll head that way and I think a lot of
the team will our team's expanded we've
grown so but it is very different game
you know so I think the bigger
challenges are scope and scale it's a
big game it's much bigger you know we
did we didn't we had to do four we'd
never done a horse before we mocap toe
horse which I still don't understand
that how you do that but so there are a
lot of challenges but you know what the
darker kind of more serious tone hasn't
been as hard it's actually been one of
them more ya know fun bar fun parts
actually it's challenging because you
got to figure out how much violence you
want and when you like this we sit just
heads are going off everywhere and just
violence is a tool for storytelling so
if you're gonna see that level of
violence it's going to be in moments
where there's narrative impact yeah it's
not like the comic book II violence
anymore right
yeah it's just very I mean we showed you
know chopping a hand off and in the
and the demo because we want people to
know that you we're gonna deliver on
that part of the fantasy but it's not
gratuitous on every hit you're not doing
that it's meant to be impactful just
doing it all over the place that kind of
undermines that if you're trying to tell
us really serious story so right and
speaking of the story how difficult is
it to so at the beginning that demo it
said you know like Mongol invasion day9
everything is it kind of gonna be like a
time thing that you have to as we're
going it's gonna be a different day how
do you encourage players to sort of not
get give them the freedom to control the
open world but not but also kind of
nudge them onto that critical path yeah
so the the actual game is its dynamic
dynamic time of day it kind of continues
and goes and actually one of the demo is
kind of interesting because for us it's
actually not a golden path mission it's
actually a silver side path mission in
the game and we did that because one of
the messages we really want to share
about the game is that it's a big a big
world go to it you can you can if you
can see it you can go to it you can do
it and we want to showcase that we're
aiming for these interesting side
stories in the game and the more
interesting I think about that that's
that's we call it a prefecture stamp but
a stamp that comes up when the gameplay
kind of starts is actually the big kanji
that you see in the text underneath
isn't the same in this particular
scenario that actually says the forest
of no return and that is a theme for the
force that you're going into for that
section of the world all the stories
that you'll you'll you'll engage with
have a little bit of a darker undertone
to them and so our game is so big we we
have to figure out a way to chunk it up
until oh these kinds of stories here
these kinds of stories here so we have
art themes and narrative themes to go
along with them and so this one features
betrayal right though it's so we have a
couple different methods to help people
kind of experience the world and see a
variety across the whole thing I'm
curious like going back to the very very
early days this game like drawing board
days brainstorming meetings did you know
right away that it was gonna be you
wanted to do open-world set in Japan or
was there where there's some aspects
that you knew right away that you want
to do and that just stuck throughout the
years or are a lot of them something
that just developed over time
we when we when we finished first light
after taking a little break because we
had just come off second Sun went
straight into first light we we
immediately started working on a new
game and and when we got to the point
where this this was on the drawing board
and we were sketching it out and we had
you know started talking with some of
our you know sony partners and execs and
it was pretty clear we really wanted to
do it we're excited about it and we just
kind of kind of went off from there
pretty quickly but actually truthfully
the first thing we as soon as you say
you want to put a horse's in a game that
means a different type of long term
traversal right like you know terrain
okay if you don't have train that means
you have to develop stack for terrain so
you have to instantly start going on all
these things that you know game like
infamous just doesn't require because
it's just completely different yeah so
we knew pretty early and when we when we
found out you know that's what we were
going to do like we just started
building the giant list of things that
need to get done and then we're here
today
well Jason thank you so much for joining
us yeah no release date just yet now
29th I yeah yeah well you can tell us we
won't I'll turn these mics down yeah but
thank you so much for joining us all
right guys if you're watching at home
make sure to stick around next up on the
stage we're gonna have Soul Calibur six
[Music]